in early August 1914 we know that
Germany declares war on Russia just as
Russia's mobilizing troops to get into a
war with the Austria Austria Hungarian
Empire because the austro-hungarians
have declared war on Serbia and the
Russians apparently or ostensibly or or
use or use protection of Serbia as a
pretext for getting into war with the
Austrians the Germans have an alliance
with the Austrian so they feel the need
to fight the Russians and then because
the Russians have an alliance with the
French to fight the French as well the
first actual combat on the Eastern Front
actually happens with Russia on the
offensive and you actually have two
Russian armies the Russian 1st army in
the Russian Second Army attacking the
Germans up here in Eastern Prussia and
they were going against one one German
army the German 8th army and in theory
it should have been a rout of the German
8th army they had him outnumbered you
had two Russian armies coming from
different directions but because of a
really bad coordination and one could
even argue bad leadership and other
tactical problems it was actually a rout
the other way so the war World War 1 on
the Eastern Front starts very badly with
the for the Russians you actually have a
huge rout of them at the Battle of
Tannenberg Tannenberg and Tannenberg xin
teresting because it actually did not
even happen in Tannenberg Tannenberg is
right around here was it far from the
point of the battle but there was other
cities that would have been more the
battle could have been named for but
since the Germans won the battle they
named at Tannenberg because there was an
ancient battle in medieval times in the
1400s where the Slavic some Slavic
people's were able to rout German
Teutonic Knights we're talking about
medieval battles with Knights and in
order to redeem that they labeled this
other war where was Germans against
Slavic people they said oh this is our
second battle for Tannenberg so it
helped it helped bring out more I guess
bit German patriotism but this was a
major major major route for the Russians
the Second Army in particular got
completely decimated the second army the
Russian second army went into the battle
I've seen estimates of 150,000 to
180,000 troops
roughly half were killed roughly half
were killed and only about 10,000
escaped the Battle of Tannenberg and was
so such a humiliating defeat for the
Russian Second Army but that the general
of the Russian second army general
General Samsonov and I'm sure once again
I'm mispronouncing everything General
Samsonov actually shot himself he
committed suicide he was so humiliated
and so embarrassed by that defeat so the
war did not begin well for the Russians
but by the end of 1914 they were able to
I guess get back into gear and and they
stayed on the offensive and they did
have some victories up here in Galicia
which at the time was part of
northeastern Hungary and so they were
actually able to capture a good bit of
territory right over here now as we
enter into 1915 and we've already
covered this on the videos on the
Western Front we know that the Western
Front was entering into a stalemate the
sleepin´ plan did not happen as quickly
as possible but the defenders had a huge
advantage so that gave the Germans an
opportunity to bring some troops back to
the Eastern Front to bring troops back
to the Eastern Front they also got
better at coordinating with the
austro-hungarians and so you have 1915
you have the Central Powers go back on
the offensive
so Central Powers go back on the
offensive go back on the offensive and
they're essentially able to drive the
Russians out of Russian Poland so
they're able to drive the Russians out
of Russian Poland roughly to this border
that I had drawn right over here roughly
to this border give or take right over
here when we talk about Russian Poland
the the modern state of poor Poland I'm
making this video now in 2013 the modern
state of Poland was essentially split
between what you see in this map between
the Russian Empire and the journal
German Empire the modern state of Poland
is roughly is roughly this region this
region right over here and so you see
it's almost it's completely split almost
like a yin-yang sit yin and yang symbol
between these two between these two
empires but by but through nine
fifteen the Russians were pull were
pushed out of Russian Poland roughly to
this border and essentially to a large
degree was because Russia even though
they had this this huge army this this
huge manpower they had bad communication
lines and actually had bad technical
supplies Russian industry wasn't able to
keep up with the demand of the war and
wasn't able to supply the munitions in
improper quantities and the arms and
proper quantities to their troops as you
enter into 1916 the Russians once again
were able to get their footing back as
you can see it starting to become a
little bit of a back and forth so
Russian industry Russian industry
industry I guess you could say picks
back up in 1916 and it essentially puts
the Russians more on the offensive they
were driven out of Russian Poland but
now by 1916 they're able to keep the
Central Powers a little bit more on the
defensive but the the boundaries of the
front roughly stay roughly stay in line
with this line right over here and by
the end of 1916 you actually have the
Romanians joining on the side of the
triple on Tonto
Nord er to fight in order to fight the
central the Central Powers as well now
this might look like it's starting to
look better for the Russians the
Russians their industry is finally
picking up they're starting to put the
central powers a little bit more on the
defensive but the entire time that we're
talking about this battle does the
economic situation in the Russian Empire
is deteriorating dramatically by the
time you get into 1917 the Russian
economy so the Russian the Russian
economy is really falling apart you have
food shortages you have riots food
shortages you have riots and in February
of 1917 you have the February revolution
you essentially the the overthrow of the
Romanov dynasty it's been in power for
three hundred years but you have Tsar
Nicholas the second so this is in
February February and then in early
March you have Tsar Tsar Nicholas
Nicholas the second abdicates the throne
and this is the gentleman right here and
we'll do more detailed videos about the
entire Russian Revolution and what
happens to his family and all of the
rest and you have an interim government
that takes place and this is actually a
little this is an interesting fact of
history this interim government all of a
sudden becomes a democracy this is
February 1917 remember the United States
has not entered the war at this point
but you might also remember that in
April the United States uses the idea of
fighting on the side of democracy as a
justification for entering the war which
is very nice because by April all of the
major powers on the side of the I guess
you could say the triple entendre T's
you're talking about now the interim
government for the Russians you have the
French and you have the British Empire
obviously it's a democracy only for
those who were voting and actually the
the United States was the first company
the first country to recognize the
interim government after the overthrow
of Tsar Nicholas ii but we're not just
done with 1917 1917 is one of those huge
years in the history of the world and
especially in the history of russia the
situation continues to deteriorate and
it starts to deteriorate as well for the
army you the the morale and the troops
break down you start having the
Bolsheviks start to kind of create
unrest the by the end of 1917 now we're
talking about September 1917 so that's
maybe right around here you have the
Central Powers Germany is able to
capture Riga which is a major which is a
major city right over here on the Baltic
which brings which brings the the the
the Central Powers very very close to
the Russian capital it contributes to
the ongoing unrest that's going on and
so in November November November 7th you
have a coup d'etat of that ostensibly
democratic interim government
provisional government and you have the
Communist take power you have the
Bolsheviks take power under the
leadership of Vladimir Lenin right over
here so November 7 1917 very famous date
in
Street you have the bolshevik so this is
Lenin leading the Bolsheviks into power
now they were in no interest to continue
fighting this battle with Germany they
had their own civil war to worry about
they were trying to consolidate power in
Russia so in December they essentially
get into start to negotiate an armistice
with the Central Powers and there they
did not have a lot of leverage and then
in this negotiation because they weren't
they really did not want to be in this
war and so by March of 1918 March of
1918 you have the treaty this is between
Russia and the Central Powers the Treaty
of Brest and I'm sure I'm mispronouncing
everything brest-litovsk lata Fisk
little disc the Treaty of brest-litovsk
in which the Russians because they were
so desperate the Bolsheviks were so
desperate in order to get to kind of
focus on the internal civil war that had
emerged in Russia in order to
consolidate power
they gave her over a huge amount of
territory to the Central Powers and
essentially a large part of European
Russia that is not predominantly have
Russia is not predominantly of Russian
ethnicity went over to the Central
Powers now this treaty is important
because it essentially was the end of
World War one for the Russians it
essentially was the end of the Eastern
Front and it allowed the Germans to then
refocus on the Western Front which
allowed the Germans to start bringing
troops back over back over to the
Western Front and they were actually
able to do quite an aggressive Spring
Offensive on the Western Front and if it
wasn't for the u.s. at the time now
being able to reinforce the Western
Front remember they declared war in mid
1917 it's not clear that the the German
offensive might not have been successful
in the spring of 1918 so the importance
of brest-litovsk is it was the end of
the Eastern Front it allowed the brittle
out of the Germans to do an offensive on
the Western Front and it was a it was it
was a very strong offensive but with the
help of the Americans it was not a
successful one but the actual
territorial gains for the central power
of brest-litovsk I'm sure I'm
mispronouncing it were not that
significant because
in November 1918 and here I'm probably
falling off my timeline a little bit but
right over here in November 1918 this is
maybe nineteen this is 1919 right over
here you have the the Central Powers
essentially saying oh my god we're not
going to be able to win this war and you
have the essentially what's was for a
long time known as Armistice Day the
11th day of the 11th month or the 11th
hour of the 11th month of or the 11th
hour of the 11th day of the 11th month
you have an armistice and you have the
end of world war 1 with the Allies
winning and so the Allies got to say
what happened to this territory right
over here